-There's so much good stuff
happening this summer.
I'm reading.
I'm getting into that.
There's good TV. I'm watching
my "Below Deck Med."
Is it Med? Yeah.
Captain Sandy is the greatest.
I'm watching --
"Big Brother" is good.
-Yeah!
-Right? It is good.
There's so many good
documentaries out there.
Quest's "Summer of Soul"
is available.
That's out right now on Hulu.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's unbelievable.
But, you know, I'm a big fan of
reality shows.
So, I just heard about this.
There's a new show on Fox
they're developing
called "Mouse Trap,"
and it's based on
the Hasbro game Mouse Trap.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I got to be --
I'm having a hard time
imagining it because...
[ Laughter ]
...a TV show based on
a board game.
I mean, I'm serious.
I don't have a clue
what they would look like.
[ Laughter ]
It seems like a huge risk.
I mean, who's in charge of
this operation, you know?
Who's the mastermind?
You know, I can't even guess
who would do this.
Some people think
it's a trivial pursuit.
Like complete balderdash,
you know?
It really does boggle my mind
because I'm not convinced
it's up to par, cheesy
as that might sound.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And this could get me in trouble
because it's taboo to say.
But the premise just doesn't
connect for me.
[ Laughter ]
And if someone asked me to be
on the show, I'd say "ew, no,"
because I don't know...
[ Laughter ]
...anything about board games.
Sorry!
[ Cheers and applause ]